colombia vive su tercera semana de paro
nacional y lo hace con la denuncia de
human rights watch de al menos 55
muertos desde que iniciase en las
protestas el 28 de abril algo que su
director ejecutivo josé miguel vivanco
ha calificado de aterrador el lunes el
presidente iván duque ordenó el máximo
despliegue posible de fuerza pública
para levantar unos bloqueos que rigen en
todo el país por parte de manifestantes
que están causando desabastecimiento en
las principales ciudades así como
pérdidas millonarias en el gremio de
empresarios el comité nacional de paro
ya está marchando en este punto y en
otros de la ciudad y del país y está en
diálogos con el gobierno nacional de
iván duque para un nuevo contrato social
un nuevo contrato social que los jóvenes
ven con escepticismo ya que exigen al
gobierno una condena firme de la
violencia policial así como acceso al
alimento al empleo ya la educación
después de que se conociese tras la
pandemia un 42 por ciento de pobreza en
colombia las manifestaciones del 28 de
abril han provocado la retirada de la
polémica reforma tributaria
además también
la renuncia del ministro de hacienda
alberto carrasquilla sin embargo lo que
están pidiendo y los manifestantes son
cambios estructurales